the next aggressive opening to make our
list is the scotch Gambit this is the
scotch game the scotch game is typically
pretty slow pretty boring and so someone
came up with the scotch gambits uh which
makes it all the more interesting so
after the pawn takes here on D4 White's
going to forego taking this material
here on D4 you know you could see an
exchange of the knights and the Knights
here but instead White's going to play
Bishop here to C4 and he's gonna have a
very very strong attack that he's going
to start so again the scotch Gambit if
you're definitely looking for a way to
kind of spice up the scotch game this is
definitely your opening